foreign
it's nazarez and welcome to the Rotten
Tomatoes binge guy today we're bringing
you five very bingeable titles based on
the hit Apple TV Plus show Severance one
of my ultimate favorites now this sci-fi
mystery drama Stars Adam Scott is an
employee who agrees to have his non-work
memory separated from his work memories
if only we could do that in real life
I'm just kidding I love working here it
was created by Dan Erickson marking his
first major Hollywood project with Ben
Stiller serving as an executive producer
and also director of six of the first
Nine episodes and I really do love
working here Severance which was
influenced by things like the urban
legend known as the back rooms and the
film film The Truman Show was nominated
for 14 Emmy Awards in 2022 including
Outstanding Drama Series and outstanding
lead actor in a drama for Adam now it
took Stiller and Company nearly five
years to go from a script that he loved
to a hit show on Apple and now it was
renewed for a second season you gotta
love it
did you lie about the number of people
in your department
because
we don't trust you guys you the king of
don't trust us I do but people just talk
about MDR stupid old stories jokes even
what do you mean not here
it's literally silly like they say you
all have pouches
pouches like to carry young yes so while
we wait for that here are five other
shows you can totally binge if you love
Severance on today's binge guide
starting with our brand new pick Kindred
now this FX mini-series arrived in
December of 2022 and quickly became
fresh with critics and a hit with
viewers adapted from award-winning
author Octavia e Butler's celebrated
novel of the same name Kindred Stars
Mallory Johnson as a young black woman
an aspiring writer who relocates to LA
in search of a bright new future but
before she can get too comfortable she
finds herself being pulled back and
forth in time and ends up at a 19th
century Plantation with intimate ties to
her own family's history now with the
fresh Tomato Meter score around 62
percent critics have had plenty to say
about this adaptation during a short
time with us like Quincy lagardi from AV
club who call this series quote a
compelling thought-provoking scenario in
a well-written and expertly directed
package now the novel was also adapted
as a graphic novel back in 2017 if
you're into that sort of thing but if
you're more into sitting on your couch
like me and not moving for long periods
of time like me it'll take you eight
hours to binge this one so I guess
you're welcome
how long was I gone less than a minute
not even seconds it felt like I was gone
for an hour
I know how this sounds
[Music]
surprise
not crazy
whatever this is
it's real
[Music]
next up our certified fresh pick this
week is Legion now this sci-fi drama
from FX ran for three straight certified
fresh Seasons from 2017 to 2019. the
show is set in an alternate timeline of
the X-Men film series and was
co-produced by Marvel it's about a
diagnosed schizophrenic played by Dan
Stevens who discovers special powers
that he has to learn how to control and
live with all while evading a government
agency Legion was created by Noah Hawley
The Man Behind the Fargo series on FX
and the cast also includes names like
Gene Smart and our girl Aubry Plaza from
White Lotus season 2 who earned a MTV
movie and TV award nomination for best
villain for this show the critics
consensus calls Legion quote a
singularly piece of visually arresting
mind-bending television that never fails
to surprise with polygons Tasha Robinson
adding quote it's weird and often
unsettling and nightmarish but it's also
pretty mesmerizing now you can binge all
three seasons in around 27 hours and
when you do keep an ear out for the
heavy influence of Pink Floyd used by
Noah Holly throughout I think Sid's in
trouble we need to split up now Carrie
and I Look for Sid Mellie you and Paul
find fokiana oh what if we see the Monk
ask him what he wants just don't get too
close you should be immune now but we
are yeah I did a little thing before we
left he did a thing in my head just
don't get too close what about the cow
oh in my lap guys
let's check the pedestal first next up
is our throwback pick Logan's Run now
from the same people behind Charlie's
Angels this action series was released
in the fall of 1977 on CBS and is based
on the 1976 film of the same name which
in turn was based off the Logan's Run
novel from 1967. in this series Gregory
Harrison serves as Logan a 26 year old
police assassin living in a totalitarian
future where no one is permitted to live
beyond age 30. when he begins to
question the lethal nature of his work
he goes on the run in search of an
idyllic place where people can actually
live once again in peace and gasp into
their 40s now the series differs from
the plot of the movie in a few ways the
biggest of which is the inclusion of an
Android called REM who assists to show
his main protagonist throughout and who
did not appear in the film Logan's Run
had a few of the same writers as the
original Star Trek series that was
popular at the time but what it didn't
have and Star Trek did was a big budget
for effects which is why some feel this
series was canceled after its 14 episode
first season critic Joan Irwin from the
Montreal Gazette wrote about the series
in 2021 saying that it has a lightness
and a lack of solemnity that is
appealing calling it quote the kind of
innocent Adventure that may have wide
appeal for young viewers Logan's Run
picked up a Saturn award nomination back
in 2013 for best Blu-ray television
release and while it wasn't around quite
long enough to have its own toy line
produced although prototypes were made
it is just the right length for a good
solid binge weekend at just under 14
hours for the whole thing boom so you're
Logan and Jessica we've been expecting
you I'm Joanna and this is the protector
Karen told us that you rule Sanctuary
that's an overstatement here each man
rules himself well
that was done so that the runners who
came here would feel more at home are
they happy oh yes each is free to live
in the manner that suits him best
you have no idea how much this means to
us and sancom is our under the radar
pick this week is Maniac this Netflix
miniseries probably wasn't really Under
The Radar Radar when it dropped in 2018
but may have slipped from public
awareness since then so allow us to
remind you about it very Loosely based
on a 2015 region series of the same name
this one is from The Leftovers writer
Patrick Somerville and popular director
Carrie joji fukunaga it stars Emma Stone
and Jonah Hill along with others like
Justin throw Sally Field and Ozarks
Julia Garner in supporting roles Now set
in a retro future in New York City it
honestly looks so cool Maniac follows a
group of strangers who are drawn to a
mysterious pharmaceutical trial that
promises to fix all of their problems
but doesn't quite go as planned now this
certified fresh miniseries picked up
quite a few Award nominations including
sag and satellite award knobs for Emma
Stone's performance and along with
viewers and Award nominations the show
was a hit with critics too Lauren
Carroll Harris from the guardian said
quote Maniac actually has something
profound to say about the alienation of
people today while the overall critics
consensus says that this series quote
enthralls with its dazzling visuals
adventurous narrative and striking
performances from both Stone and hill
now six and a half hours is all you need
a binge just Netflix miniseries which
when you take out trips to the bathroom
and being on Tick Tock is like a solid
work day am I right you found it just
now and
call the cops and clear this whole thing
no Bruce I can't call the cops this is
an illegal lemur if they take her
they're gonna ship her back to
Madagascar plus Nan told me that it had
to be me only me she was very specific
on that point
I just
gotta break into that store
and finally for our editor's pick this
week they have selected counterpart now
this star show is two 100 certified
fresh seasons and was created by Justin
marks best known for writing Disney's
live-action remake of The Jungle Book
this series features a dual performance
from Oscar winner JK Simmons playing
characters from parallel Dimensions In
Cold War era Berlin now once he
discovers a multi-dimensional secret
he's immersed in a Mysterious World of
Espionage and government conspiracies
keeping Praise on the Fantastic work
from Simmons was a common theme from
critics like the Sydney Morning Herald's
Brad Newsom who said that JK quote
delivers two spellbinding performances
and the overall critics consensus cause
counterpart quote an absorbing thrill
Fest which finds time to deliver
relevant societal critiques after Stars
opted out of doing more episodes The
Producers shopped at elsewhere in hopes
of a Lifeline but that never came ending
its run after two seasons and 20
episodes it'll take you right around 20
hours to binge this one and that should
also be an enough time to figure out if
you want to meet your counterpart From
Another Dimension I came because I I
thought I was doing the right thing
and and then I saw what he had
and I just
I am not
him
I know I would
[Music]
well my friends there you have it five
shows that you can binge right now if
you are having Severance withdrawals
like me I know how those can be they are
just not good but like I said Severance
season two will be coming but hopefully
we piqued your interest on a couple
other similar options in the meantime
and by the way if you're looking to find
more great shows for binging purposes be
sure to grab a copy of our book ultimate
binge guide it is full of special list
that features some of the best shows of
all time and as always don't forget to
find us again for more selections based
on the shows and movies that you love it
is all right here on the Rotten Tomatoes
binge guide I'm nazarez and I'll see you
guys next time
foreign